welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit www.solarwatcher.net in
Explorer for about six years and my job
on that on that project is really
relevant to this book because my job
there at the young age of 22 or 23 was
to lead a project team and trying to
come up with new ideas for how to make
the web better this is like 1995 this is
the beginning of the web for how to make
the web better for people how to make it
easier to use and how to companies these
ideas and develop them and ship them so
my job was to develop these ideas work
with designers and engineers and put
them into specifications and then help
the team leave the team and engineering
and stuff and getting out the door so my
job was innovation that's what I felt my
job was it's what I was told was
supposed to do the problem was I really
had no idea how to do it and I had a
really hard time getting information
about how do you innovate how do you
manage a team that's supposed to be
innovating creating new stuff and even
though I knew a lot of people at
Microsoft who had been there longer than
me and I knew other people in the
industry who are inventors people worked
on the Macintosh people would work on
UNIX as much as I tried to get
information about what's the process
what's the plan how do you do this I
found that most of what people knew or
pet theories there were stories legends
and mythologies and a lot of them even
though they were experiencing has been
successful put a lot of faith in things
that did not have a lot of substance so
at that time I started saying you know I
got to get more informed about this I
want to find out of all the people who
have done this before I have how did
they do it
and not that not know what do we think
about what they did not what do we
masala gize what we put into the films
where they actually do so I started
reading about Edison story reading back
to Vinci right about 4 and I started
reading about all these people don't
wanted to understand what was their
playbook how do they think about what
they did so over the course of my career
this was just a side project I wasn't
really that interested in history when I
was a student even though I took history
classes I wasn't
interested and eventually though I built
this knowledge up and I was successful
as a manager I worked in some stuff that
I feel was good software despite where I
worked and when I left Microsoft 2003 my
ambition was to write books the first
book I wrote was about management how do
you manage teams of people good book did
really well they well enough they wanted
me to write a second book my second book
I'm like a god to write about this
innovation stuff because most of the
books about innovation are so focused on
hype and mythology and romance and
that's not that useful if you want to be
a practitioner so who here wants to be
an innovator when they think of
themselves and they're dead and why on
there was an innovator in their field
who here most of you right certainly in
America innovation is it's a high-minded
idea we all want to be innovators so I'm
going to talk to you about here it kind
of it's a kind of a dovetailing of the
stuff in the book a lot of the stories
I'm going to tell you are actually not
in the book but the themes are the same
so before we do that before we do that I
got to do a little bit of I don't know
innovation trivia just to warm you up
and make sure we all you know we know
who we're talking about so I'm gonna
show some pictures of famous innovators
in different fields I just want you to
yell out what you think it is so who's
this guy thank God is it easy one how
about this guy
Edison pretty good this is very young
picture of Edison he's usually shown as
much older guy next to the light bulb
all right we got this guy No Oh younger
than Galileo artist no Michelangelo hey
Claire Joe Bob Dylan the Apple is a
giveaway okay and we got this guy
another giveaway all right so we got six
innovators and there's one important
theme
look the biographies of all these people
there's one theme that runs through all
of them okay well guess what it is I'm
sorry
fail out of school you're on the right
track she's on the right track on the
right track some of you say bad hair
true
they're all men also true most of them
are dead also true but she's on the
right track so none of these people got
a degree in innovation management
learning them read a book on how
innovation happens not a creative
thinking class
none of them followed any of the things
that today we'd like to promote as
that's how you do it that there's a
school or system that you have to learn
all these people had the same trait
which was they believed in an idea that
they thought was interesting or they
cared about and they followed it
sometimes to their depression in the
case of Van Gogh sometimes to their
financial misery in the case of actually
Edison Edison was not a particularly
successful businessman he tried to be
but he was not so the thing that the key
thing here is that we like to think that
innovation is this grand thing that is
only accessible to certain people who
follow certain rules or certain
credentials and the history of animation
says the opposite it's often the
renegades it's often the delinquents
it's often people who say you know what
I am NOT gonna follow what everyone else
is doing
I'm gonna go over here so it's a very
democratic notion you don't there's no
there's no official pedigree you have to
have in order to qualify as an innovator
in any field now one problem that we
have though is we like there that we
like to believe that you need a pedigree
it's a very convenient and historic
belief it's only special people are
creative the only people can be
musicians or artists or writers or
people who were gifted who are born as
geniuses or prodigies it's a very
romantic and very popular notion so one
particular mythology that's part of that
romance is the myth of Epiphany and it's
the idea it's magic moments that define
what innovation is now if you have a
magic moment happen see that's what
determines whether you will have a
breakthrough or not and if you don't
have a magic moment happen to you well
hey wasn't your fault just the muse did
not bless you so a story in Newton
anyone want to give me the twenty second
TV commercial version of the Newton
Apple story anybody
thirty-second version right intimidated
you I don't know yeah
came up with gravity who hears heard
that story does anyone know where they
heard it school I was talking to Eton's
class yesterday the joke I made was
where I heard it was School House Rock
City say see if the carp knows you don't
know it's a cartoon very popular
American cartoon in the late 70s where
they would show these educational things
it was it was a cartoon to break up the
cartoons yeah very anyway that's the
source for a lot of these these myths
carry on all these places that we don't
think of as educational sources but yet
we know the Manulife anyway this story
is the canonical epiphany story because
it says that there's a singular moment
in time when one individual who as far
as we know in the story was not
particularly intelligent or gifted my
accident was struck violently by a piece
of fruit and that's why we know about
gravity now we all you guys are smart
right I know you guys all got into
Carnegie Mellon it's not easy to do or
you're wandering off the street it's
hard to find this room so I know I know
that you guys are smart but we tend not
to think too much about these myths they
sit there in the back of our minds and
when we're not paying attention they
influence what we believe should be
happening so when you're working really
hard to solving a problem and there's no
magic moment there's no Epiphany we tend
to lose faith that somehow we're not
doing it right so the church story for
Newton the Apple is a much larger more
complicated story that a it probably
didn't even happen probably didn't
happen but even if it did happen the
real value of the story isn't where he
was and the day he thought about gravity
because he'd been thinking about gravity
for a long time we didn't discover
gravity I mean he was alive in the late
17th century we knew about gravity for a
long time before then so the idea he
discovered something that late in
history is kind of a ridiculous notion
but anyway given what he actually was
famous for was proving the mathematics
of gravity proving the science behind
how it worked so you could be predictive
about how gravitational fields work and
it took her about 15 years to do that
they actually document all the math
required we don't fully know if she was
kind of a recluse and he wrote a lot of
stuff on his own and didn't publish it
until someone else threatened to publish
like oh I already did that and throw out
the paper and had already done it so we
don't really know how long it took him
but it took him a long amount of time
and the value of the story to us and why
carries on as a myth is it absolves us
all these but if any mythology z'
absolve us is the pressure of the work
involved behind any breakthrough
innovation we've ever heard of there's
another famous story about an epiphany
anybody know Eureka so what's the Eureka
story the 22nd TV commercial version
that's okay now tell me what you know
Archimedes okay Wow that's pretty good
pretty good all right you're a history
major okay so how do you know the story
your mom always trust your mom it's good
advice okay so she's actually got the
story pretty right that but what this
person that I get for most people
including very well respected
intelligent innovators themselves they
say there's something about bathtub and
he yelled out something and ran into the
streets naked that's the version of
rustic we'll remember anytime you can
get you know someone yelling and running
naked it's gonna be the parts that
people remember so it's another example
of why is that part of the story useful
how if you want to be an inventor you
want to have the next breakthrough in
science and next breakthrough in
computer science the next breakthrough
in literature how does knowing about the
bathtub help you it doesn't it's a
comical story that makes the whole idea
of invention seem trivial he was just in
a bathtub I'm in bathtubs nothing
happened to me all right I guess I'm not
special I'm not gifted so you can find
these epiphanies stories everywhere you
can find them in stories about business
success you can find them in stories of
literature success you can find the
memory because they are comfortable
they're funny they're entertaining and
they they're kind of a music and they
deflate all the work and all the stuff
behind it the absolute true story of
Archimedes is our communities was kind
of like Newton he was a scientist he was
an observer of the world and he spent
most of his life doing experiment asking
questions and the problem he was trying
to solve we don't want to know that much
about the history because the whole way
that story was told is actually pretty
sketchy but what we do know is that it's
probably not
the only moment he's spent thinking
about the problem what probably happened
was he was working the problem got kind
of stressed out about it because he kept
failing took a bath to relax and in the
relaxation to subconscious help process
the work he's been doing and he came up
with an idea that he hadn't thought of
before so you can find lots and lots of
examples of these now one of the things
that came up in research for the books
the books about innovation but a big
part of what innovation usually means
creative thinking how do you invent how
do you develop a new idea how do you
find alternatives that people haven't
thought of before so in part of
preparation for the book and part of
preparation for this course that I've
talked to University of Washington I
became a student of the psychological
literature of creative thinking and I
read all the journals I could find with
all the books about creative thinking
and there's this popular notion about
creativity it's reflected in these
epiphany stories about there being you
know it's just discrete thing the idea
is a discrete thing there's a moment in
time and you can just slowly you could
control those moments and put them in a
jar whenever you had this tough problem
just took a thing there's like a pill
and you could just magically do and
that's how we conventionally think of
what creativity is and people who took
this course they wanted the same thing
that wanna know how do i manufacture an
idea
now all the psychology behind creative
thinking and how our brains work and how
we develop ideas talks about the value
of habits the creative people have
different habits for how they use ideas
and how they play with ideas and how
much time they spend seeking
alternatives and how lower their
inhibitions are to considering things
that we filter out right away the crazy
ideas the odd idea is the scary ideas
they are more comfortable having the
habit of entertaining those ideas for a
longer period of time so it's about
habits which means that really the
question asked if ever hear a story
about an epiphany or a magic moment the
magic moment isn't going to inform you
but what happened to 10 minutes before
an hour before a week before what was
that person doing how does this magic
moment fit into their pattern of
behavior if you can learn the patterns
of behavior then there's something you
can probably replicate or emulate or
borrow from or inform you about what
process you need to follow to be more
creative that's the first thing you
think about habits the moments aren't
that important if the habits that lead
to the moments so in all these stories
it's interesting to think about this is
like an iceberg that we focus on these
magicals these little stories the show
in movies or in TV shows and we don't
talk nearly as much about all the stuff
that had to happen to make that moment
possible it's a last little anecdote
just to see innovation trivia who here
knows a story about the invention of the
telephone in the back yeah okay do you
know his store uh : ventures okay I'm
looking for another anecdote he's
actually got fast looking for an
anecdote that people might anyone know
story what was the first word said
Watson come here so he was hurt and
heard that before Watson come here okay
now if you want to invent something that
replaced the telephone how would your
knowledge of what were the first words
were help you would that be helpful in
any way at all totally useless
information so most of what we know
about creative thinking and innovation
is it's largely trivia which is fun it's
entertaining what do well for you on
Jeopardy but not going to get you it's
not going to help you to create
something it's going to replace these
things that we know another mythology
comes into play when we talk about
science and a lot of the science that
that we're taught the way science is
taught is usually following the
footsteps of what's been done before so
even though the words experiments and
scientific methods show up a lot in
science education in you know elementary
school in high school it's very rare for
people in those situations to actually
get to do an experiment themselves where
they're asking questions that don't have
clear answers so we talk about science
and the scientific method or rocket
science and those things we have a very
biased notion as to what that means
because if you're talking about
breakthroughs in science the patterns
that they follow are much more familiar
to our human nature than we like to
think so one of the best biographies are
something like documentary it's a
nonfiction book about scientific
breakthrough is this book a double helix
and it's about the discovery of DNA and
I picked up this book a long time ago as
part of my one no how did these guys
think they follow the same prototyping
and iteration cycles that I did for
software they have hypotheses and
explore an event what whether they are
you know faculty members what are the
research grant people say about their
crazy idea and this book is great
because it has so little about science
in it it's largely a human story of a
bunch of people who had an idea that mo
people didn't agree didn't agree was
possible who pursued hunches they
pursued intuition they followed very
instinctive instinctive motivations for
the research that they pursued and it's
backed up by science I'm not saying they
weren't scientists but the motivating
force was purely human it was not a
logic formula it wasn't they followed
here's the floor you know here's these
three steps we have to follow unit
number four and then we'll discover DNA
it was much more intuitive and ad hoc
than that and anytime we're talking
about discovery or breakthrough that is
true no matter what the field is there's
another side effect of the way we talk
about breakthroughs now has to do with
them failure if you're going to talk
about a little bit deeper in a second
I'm gonna touch on it right now that has
to do with them architecture and the
icons that we used to signify great
engineering work the great you know
pinnacle moments of Western civilization
and we like to talk about Greece and
Rome all the time we're kind of
infatuated with them and in some cases
for good reason when it comes to
architecture the certain fallacy in the
stories we tell so this is a the
Colosseum in Rome that was building
wonderfully architected and we like to
talk with these buildings and talking
about the Romans for how their stuff is
held up for so long these buildings of
2,000 years old it's amazing
the problem is we don't see the
buildings that were made really badly
you know why because they fell down
they're gone they fell over and they
were scrapped for parts or bearing or
used for other things so over time this
is a problem in general history but
specific to innovation history over time
all the failures and mistakes that were
necessary to create this building kind
of get buried and like I talked about
knew as much you can't go to Rome and
visit here is the first attempt to make
the Colosseum that fell over and killed
30 people there's more - right because
Rome we know and that Rome had a large
population about million people I'd
speak to million people somewhere in
that range and we also know we have this
idealized notion in America who's never
see a movie belt room we focus on the
the wealthy classes and everything's
marble and beautiful and there's buffets
and orgies and it's just like a pinnacle
Wow everything's pleasure and wonderful
now that was true but the problem is
that was only true for a very small part
of the pop
so when there was a fire in Rome during
Nero's reign
there's a fire in Rome and about
two-thirds of the city burned down now
marble does not burn doesn't burn
what does burn crappy wood buildings so
this is it with there's not a whole lot
of history about the slums in Rome
because most the writing that was done
then wasn't about the crappy buildings
the writing was funded by the rich rich
wealthy people on writing about their
buildings so but this is a sketch of
what we believe they're slums look like
these things were notorious for falling
all over for crashing and there were
lots of things learned in the
construction of these buildings that
paid off in the construction the
buildings that we know that lived on
space programs similar story and is an
interesting thing about I'll talk about
the issue thing in a second so it's it
one useful thing whenever you want to
you're trying to follow the path of an
innovator trying to learn what what's
the thing I can learn from this success
you want to go back and ask where were
their failures what mistake that they
make that they learn something from it
then apply to something else and you can
find this everywhere you can find this
in the hot companies today you can find
this of the big breakthroughs of the
past this is YouTube right who here's
used you to everybody right and we talk
about YouTube while it's amazing success
these guys there's a start-up it's
bought by Google for lots and lots of
money
amazing well it turns out that the story
for how they started was that they were
trying to come up with a video
alternative to hot or not you guys know
hot or not who here has never heard of
hot or not you're gonna study break
through the innovation God study hotter
not true it's the pivotal it's the
pivotal output you missing out to the
just inform the way this works you go
there's a picture and you're supposed to
say hot or not and then there's rankings
for whose picture is hot hottest or
whatever anyway that's where they were
trying to do and in the course of trying
to do that they recognized there was a
better alternative for the stuff they
were building in this other more general
direction you find this all the time
another stories Flickr similar story
they started as a software development
game company or making an online
multiplayer game like the year 2002 2003
they went for about a year they started
to run out of funding and they
recognized it part of that game they
were building was this chat thing that
had the ability to share photos they
look at that said you know what
even though we've got this game that
we're building this little thing this
other thing is kind of it's not gonna
really materialize into something we can
make a business out of but this little
thing let's take that and make a
business out of that that's the story of
Flickr they made a mistake they learn
from it it went in a different direction
and there there we go other stories you
don't hear nearly as much as the
mythology so Apple way back when Steve
Wozniak words at EULA Packard started to
develop the idea for personal computer
and this he was working to the Packard
his first choice was to try and get EULA
Packard to make a personal computer you
didn't want taking on all the risk of
being an entrepreneur he didn't want to
take on all that all that financial risk
so he went to HP and say hey I got this
idea they turned him down found his
friend Steve and they went off in their
own direction began that way similar
story for the founders of Google this is
using doesn't come up that much anymore
but when they had their PageRank
algorithm in the beginnings of their
what would become Google they were
looking to sell their ideas to a search
engine this is like 1999-2000 somewhere
in that range and they were told by
every search engine company search
engines aren't really profitable search
engines are not really profitable that's
what they were told which makes total
sense for the time in 1999 they weren't
there were commodity so they were told
by Yahoo and I think there was probably
one or two other search engines that
they should probably go on their own if
they'd any shot of their idea ever
materialized so you always want to go
back and look for the failures and look
for the mistakes and that's how you
learn about the real process and Apple
lots of stuff to learn from there Apple
what's true but it doesn't materialize
in the and the press as much as it
should we love to talk about the iPod
the iPhone now we don't talk that much
about the Newton even though so much
stuff was learned at Apple about how you
make personal devices that knowledge
carried on and helped inform them for
what they did and there is apparently
some software from the Newton it still
lives on in the iPod operating system
and then of course other legacies that
have to be paid that the whole notion of
an iPod portable music player personal
music was really something that Sony had
the breakthrough for about thirty years
earlier you own your Apple say that ever
but it's the truth that there's a
precedent as an antecedent in the
breakthrough process that makes the
iPod success possible so we had this
weird relationship to failure in America
and how we talked about it and it's
usually only in special cases that
you'll see an entire story about a
failure now Apollo 13 is one of these
few examples it's actually a fantastic
film it's actually mostly stork the
accurate there's a really good job even
the Ron Howard directed it did a really
good job and but the story is a special
case well it's Apollo 13 so all the
chaos and uncertainty going on here well
that never happened at NASA any other
time really you know they knew what they
were doing it's rocket science after all
right which is not true it was chaos and
uncertainty in almost every mission to
some degree especially in the early
missions where failure was done by
design they had to fail in order to
learn enough to make the next mission a
possibility so to solve this first
section I got one or two more sections
to come always figure and ever hear any
stories on TV or in the news or in the
media about a magic moment the birthday
company when did you get the idea if you
want to be an innovating yourself you
need to ask the follow-up question what
were you doing before an hour before
week before month before how many
alternatives did they consider before
they settled on that idea you ask those
questions you'll start to get data it's
actually useful if you want to follow
those kinds of patterns say anything
about mistakes you want to ask what
mistake did you make that helped inform
you for the success now you're starting
getting to like the actual craft of what
it means to be creative and what it
means to work not something that becomes
a breakthrough so second thing I want to
talk about is understanding innovation
history and we're gonna do a high pop
hypothetical example here let's assume
for a second that all of us are working
together on a project so look at your
neighbors and think about whether you
really want to work with them or not
okay so we're working on project and our
goal is to innovate when a breakthrough
in you know we want to do web 4.0 we
want to come up with a new your parent
the next thing we're so far out we're
two versions ahead that's how
progressive we want to be so we starting
to make a prototype we start writing
some code or building something and it
starts to go well so we we start to make
some other prototypes and then the
process of doing that some other people
we thought we were crazy like but it's
kind of interesting can I come over and
help out it starts to grow we get more
support behind it and now there's more
people
violence we see message posts and blog
postings about what we're doing and all
of a sudden it starts there's a name for
it people start talking well something's
happening we're on the way or on the
frontier we're making change happen and
there's articles about how this is the
next new thing we're in the cover of
magazines at this point if we follow the
general case for how projects like this
go what happens next is this nothing
happens and the reason why that's so
frightening to us is because of this guy
so I'm gonna take a little tangent here
now the tangent here is about
exploration to exploration and
innovation these are like two totally
Sympatico pursuits fields that there's
so many relations between exploration
innovation and the problem has to do
with this guy because he is the only
modern icon the figure popular figure
for exploration that we have anymore
all the exploration the planet for the
most part has been done all the maps
have been drawn we know most except for
the ocean we we know most of what there
is to know and the only story that gets
told again and again and again in movies
on and on on now there's prequels and we
love exploration stories but this is the
prime model that we have and the problem
is not a real Explorer Parekh dirt TV
show right now in a TV show why should
we tell you about explorers now
explorers if any you've studied the
history like the gamma or a cook or
Magellan a lot of the time of
exploration is spent failing effectively
because they look at a map and they get
this map and there's only a little bit
on the map and everyone's like we're all
here in Europe and there's all this
black empty space with dragons and weird
stuff and the Explorers say you know I
don't really want to go to Spain or
France we've been there I'm gonna go
here and not only am I gonna go here I'm
gonna go here and find cool stuff and
I'm gonna find cool stuff and bring it
back and now that you're gonna pay me
for it
that's what every Explorer said and they
said this to royalty they said this to
people who are not you know huge risk
takers they said I'm going off the map
and as a byproduct of that the point I'm
trying to make is a byproduct of that
they spend lots of time while they're
off the map so what you know you you
kind of wander around you know it's not
there's no Google Maps there's no GPS so
you get lost you just keep going and you
think you're going in the right
direction because of the rumors you've
heard but you say smile all the time and
see lots of people dying from skirving
starvation and lots of mutinies and lots
of really unpleasant and mostly not that
interesting stuff the large percentage
of exploration is spent doing mostly not
interesting stuff work it's just hard
work that's the parallel innovation most
of what goes on innovation is not nearly
as sexy as interesting as the highlight
when you put the flag in the ground and
you get you know rewarded whatever but
the problem with kept with this guy TV
show so what happens on the TV show at
expiration TV show starts guess what
find a new planet that's the first
second second second ten seconds in some
dramatic event happens something gets
stolen somebody dies some you know
mystery happens Spock disappears who
knows and then what happens commercial
break so they have now sped through all
the parts of an exploration that are
actually the real work teleport a
transporter what drives are all
narrative devices to pass you past all
the working parts of exploration now so
Magellan oh why didn't where does
Magellan famous for oh it's too smart
too smart too smart so had you been a
less sophisticated audience who would've
said going around the world
circumnavigation now Magellan is this
guy is he correct Magellan didn't make
it he died about halfway through the
trip and he probably died as a result of
a mutiny it's not entirely clear
apparently he was put you know he
thought that all the troops are gonna
come to help defend the boat from the
natives and they'd all didn't come so he
kind of got killed and then they
continue the journey without him and
it's actually a fantastic story for
exploration or innovation the things
that went on that trip were just who if
you know the Shackleton story of the
endurance I think this is actually a
better story so I'll leave that for yes
the one book recommendation I'll give
you it there's a book called you know
the book not the endurance book
Magellan book you know okay okay you
just into it you just know connected
with it okay good man to talk to
he's got the Epiphany power so lots of
the explorers died in a similar fashion
or got lost and lots of their crew died
to cook who apparently is the model by
which Gene Roddenberry a lot of his
ideas for the show came from learning
about cook and impact the rumor is that
the reason why the Redcoats the people
who die all the time on the show the
reason why they wear red is because the
Marines in the British Navy wore red
coats and they were the first people to
go whenever they landed somewhere so
apparently that's the case so cook cook
also died he died somewhere in the
Philippines Hawaii somewhere not part of
the world alright so all these stories
that we hear about every few years
there's this new technology this new
wave and it gets hyped up in this in
this way like oh it's coming it's right
here and then it kind of doesn't
materialize that's not the fault of the
people who are working on the stuff they
were probably the people actually doing
the work were probably not that they're
probably a lot more humble than the
people writing about the work they were
doing so they were probably not that
surprised it took 10 years of 15 years
to develop whatever it was and if you
look at the real breakthroughs in
innovation history the timeline between
when the people who are working on it
felt they actually at something
interesting and it became a mass-market
something that everyone knew about is
often 15 or 20 years the mouse the
internet cell phones that trajectory
between when the person was actually
working on and actually became something
that was a phenomenon that people would
call an innovation or a breakthrough
it's a long period of time I'll talk
more about why we think it's so much
faster now than it was anyway let's
assume for a second that we're lucky and
we have a breakthrough despite all the
things we just talked about so something
was happening and then what happened we
discovered the cure for polio we we make
Windows not crash we you know we I don't
know something amazing happens what we
do it and everyone starts writing about
it and the stories they start telling
are now very different than the stories
they were telling when we were still
this ragtag bunch of crazy people
because as soon as you have success you
now have to fit into the pantheon of all
successful innovations and breakthroughs
ever in history there's a very long
story of history for any field and that
history is so much stuff in it they have
to compress it down on this date this
guy
this miss state discarded this and this
state this woman did - did - did you do
something new and as ridiculous or crazy
or risky as that was it now has to fit
into this narrative that makes things
seem obvious so all these things in the
past is the time from Wikipedia timeline
and communication technology so you got
you know smoke signals you got Morse
code Telegraph telephones if we imagine
something new that belongs in here well
you know it would show up at the bottom
of this long list and anyone who didn't
work on the thing though of course of
course web for oh there's no real risk
involved meter was whipped Rio wasn't
there so how hard could web forum have
been once you're looking backwards is
the narrative we tell is a much bigger
narrative but we want it to be all
consistent and simple so most of the
stories you read about previous
breakthroughs and innovations are of
this nature that make it seem ordinary
and simple and obvious despite how
complicated or risky it was to do so
this is an interesting example of a
better history that's full of the same
problem this is a diagram from my
publishers O'Reilly Media and they write
a lot of tech books some of you may have
heard them the animals on the cover this
is a chart they made of all of the tiger
of all the programming languages and
their relationships to each other so if
C the C++ to c-sharp and all that stuff
and it's actually a fantastic work of
design this took a lot of work to think
through and how you represent all this
stuff but the problem is that there's no
language on here that was invented
through using this diagram this was not
a tool used to invent this is a tool
used to understand or to feel good or to
get some perspective but it's not a tool
used by inventors so the view that we
get here is kind of a god-like view and
allows you to have judgment over what
happened so you look at this you say you
know object pascal what was that guy
thinking you know they got an inch
shouldn't he have nothing if I were
there I would have known the object
Pascal was never going to make it that's
the perception that you get when you
look at these quanta logical accounts so
the lesson here is that the chronologies
are like the Epiphany trivia
chronologies and dates and times are
often trivial - they don't inform you
about how that thing happened so you
want to understand what the person who
got into the history book what did they
think
what they were doing at the time what
was actually going on what were the risk
they took to actually get something
successful enough that eventually it
would be seen as obvious and become part
of the chronology okay my last um let me
just check here on time we're good we're
good
okay excellent I want to make sure it's
time for Q&A because you guys I can see
something you're like alright last thing
is about sociology so this is another
this might be my last famous history
picture anyone know what this is a this
is a picture of a famous technological
sociological event does anyone notice a
picture of yeah Luddites yeah so give me
that a 15-second very good very good who
hears heard the term Luddite
everybody good yeah and that in in my
circles my professional circles I wasn't
working the tech field for a long time
the word Luddite is a slur it's a bad
thing you say to someone when they say
you say why have you upgraded to OS 10
they go you know what you a la night
you're like resisting the future it's
somehow being a Luddite means you are I
don't know insane you're nuts you're
trying to hold on to something that
can't be hold on to so the word Luddite
is usually used as a negative a negative
thing and the this gentleman is correct
and that the story the the slightly
longer version the story is that this is
a Industrial Revolution Britain and
there were people who made their living
working in textile mills they worked on
the looms and they manually push the
looms to make these sheets of textile
and the Industrial Age was just starting
up and there was now technology that
could replace these workers automate
these workers make the looms manufacture
that would work on their own thus
eliminating the jobs and professions
that these people had so what these guys
did they showed up at work one day and
there's this loom there and their chairs
gone like what's going on their bosses
hey you know we don't need you anymore
and by the way no you would not need you
but your whole profession is gone you
know good luck see you later and they
responded violently no this it's not
clear whether this figure is fictional
or not the guy's name was supposedly Ned
Ludd Lu D V so he got the first
sledgehammer and beat the crap out of a
loom and the other people were like hey
that's not a bad idea
we pick up the looms and what are they
gonna do so they went around there kind
of like a gang and they're all rounded
up and most them are killed so that's a
story the lot it's as we usually tell it
but I'm going to tell it a different way
so how many of you have a have a job
part-time job full-time job okay bunch
of slackers here all right
okay so you can imagine imagine those of
you don't have a job imagine you had a
job and that's how you fed your family
and that was your career okay and let's
imagine after this talk you know you
you're going to go back to work tomorrow
morning you go back to work and you show
up at your desk you're all excited cuz
you want to work on your work stuff what
you like you show up and there on your
chair it's a little black box a little
red light on it where's this doing my
chairs the present it's a gift for me
that your manager comes in tapped you on
the shoulder this is how I yeah by the
way yeah we found a machine that does
your job twice as well twice as fast for
half the pay so we don't need you
anymore and by the way I don't look for
a job anywhere else because all the
other employers are doing the same thing
so goodbye now I'm sure all of you seem
like reasonable people but if you had
that box right in front of you after
being told that I'm sure you'd have a
violent response to the box you would
feel something emotional about that box
and how much from your life that box was
taking away and the lesson here is a
very important lesson about innovation
because any innovation is effectively a
kind of change it is a kind of change or
you might argue it's a positive change
that the you know the beginnings of
vaccinations was a positive change for
the world because it reduced the amount
of child illnesses or whatever you want
to say but there is change and most
people by and large fear change
especially if they are not volunteering
to participate in the change so if
you're an innovator that means you're
introducing change somewhere to your
workplace to your family to your friends
to your customers to your co-workers
you're introducing change somewhere and
if you're not aware of that change or
think about the ramification of that
change your innovation is likely to fail
now in this case there wasn't nearly
enough it wasn't nearly enough power at
the hands of these Luddites to prevent
change from happening but often in the
workplace it's so much more subtle kind
of resistance to change if I go to work
and I have a cool idea all my co-workers
might not like the fact that I'm
presenting
they didn't think of make them look bad
they're gonna resist that change my boss
might feel embarrassed the best ideas
are coming from someone that works for
him
instead of from him she's gonna suppress
those ideas he's afraid of change in
that respect so this is whole notion the
story of innovation being much more
about sociology than about technology
and this is the thing that most
technologists hate to hear they get
frustrated by the fact that even though
they could prove technologically that
their invention is superior why it takes
so long for people to acknowledge it or
use it now explains why some of these
adoption curves are so slow why the
first cell phones that were made in 1978
1979 although they were kind of like
bricks and has their problems with but
why it takes so long for these
transitions to happen it's not because
of the technology it's because of the
sociology so another reference here this
isn't my theory although it is a theory
I have a lot of affinity for this theory
comes from anthropologists and there's a
famous book called diffusion of
innovation or diffusion or diffusion of
innovation by Rogers he's an
anthropologist and he said about looking
at the history of technological
advancement from an anthropological
perspective meaning he focused on wide
certain cultures adopt certain
innovations why did some adopt clubs why
did some adopt better cooking methods
and his view was that that's really that
what precipitates or enables change to
happen it's cultural interesting theory
he looks at it for much larger view I
look at it from a very pragmatic view if
you're introducing change in your house
and your workplace in your class you
have to ask yourself who is negatively
affected by this change and how do I go
she ate that how do I overcome that how
do I either persuade them or manipulate
them or blind them or in the case of the
Luddites how do I kill them and attack
them how do I work my way around that if
you don't have that toolkit that no
matter how powerful or amazing your
innovation is it may end up not
mattering this is a really interesting
chart that I'm not going to talk about
I'll talk about it later maybe all right
so my last story for you is the most
pragmatic story that I have this is
about management and about about
breakthroughs and about it's also about
culture let me get a sip of water and
they'll keep you the closing talking
amongst yourselves for a second ok so we
got this company who here knows what 3 M
stands for Minnesota mining
manufacturing Minnesota mining and
manufacturing so who here can name a 3m
product they have used recently post-its
ok post-it note a little cute yellow
sticky thing right Minnesota and mining
yellow sticky cute they're not that much
to do with each other
now we like to think of innovations like
Google's innovative company they make
all these technological innovations but
if innovation is change positive change
or successful change then a company can
go from mining to cute little sticky
things like wow that that's a sizable
gap that's really they're stretching the
boundaries of domains and fields and
disciplines so I'm going to tell you the
story about how they got from mining to
post-it notes and the short version
stories as follows this is the early
20th century Industrial Revolution is
still big this is the rise of the
skyscrapers steel you need all these
tools and machinery parts to make steel
manufacturing work so these
entrepreneurs in Minnesota decided they
were gonna create it they're gonna
create a mining company to mine these
tools used for grinding wheels like
grind down surf metal surfaces for use
in parts and construction and they've
built this mind they're entrepreneurs of
a young man they borrowed a lot of money
they built this mine it turned out the
Marinol that they mined was the wrong
mineral it was like the equivalent of
fool's gold it was not nearly as useful
for abrasion as they thought mistake
number one they decided you know what oK
we've learned a few things
maybe we can modify this we could go in
a different direction that had a big
meaning big discussion and they decided
instead of making these two these tools
they were going to make their own kind
of sandpaper the sandpaper seems really
trivial to us now but in 1911 sandpaper
was a big deal that was like you know if
you could go and say I'm a sandpaper
engineer at a partner
Wow you get stock options with that like
you'd like that it's listen to the
rising industry right so anyway they
shifted to sandpaper they had a bunch of
other mistakes and problems they were
really not really that competent but
they persevered and by only five six
seven years later they started a
profitable sandpaper company now I'll
use your eyes on overnight success for
profitable now that's the story begins
the important part story begins here
where there was a guy who was actually
sandpaper engineer guy named Richard
drew and he was working on a project
where he had these prototypes for a new
kind of sandpaper and he was going to
one of his customers one of his clients
automobile company and they had this
problem then of trying to paint trucks
or cars two-tone colors blue and gray
and how they could come up with a
reliable way to separate the colors so
he's there and he's showing them the
sandpaper he's like hey what are you
guys doing and he gets really curious
about this problem says you know you
know I've never seen anyone saw it but I
think I can solve that problem she goes
back to work sanfur engineer right he's
got a game he's got skills he's gonna go
and figure out what to do and comes up
with a prototype comes over the
prototype doesn't quite work with a
prototype of the prototype and he's
working this for a while and eventually
his boss a guy named William McKnight
starts telling him Richard what are you
doing I'm dramatizing here okay I don't
want to projected myth this was the
literal conversation he says what are
you doing 3m you know we are Minnesota
mining manufacturing two-tone paint
doesn't fit in so get back to work on
the sandpaper stuff okay and Richard
says okay yeah posture and choice to go
back to work but this problem is sitting
there and you guys probably all had this
feeling you're working on a paper or
some school you know thing but this is
other thing that you're like I kind of
work on that
so you go eventually this back and works
on this and he's told several times by
his boss not to work on it now as the
legend goes I can't fully confirm this
part of the story but it fits so I'll
say caveat that it might be it might be
apocryphal was that he was told several
times and eventually he knew that he
needed a bunch of money to finish the
prototype so what did he do
as an engineer he had enough budget
authority to write checks to write you
know receipts for a hundred bucks and he
needed like $2,000 in the finished
prototype three writes those receipts to
himself finishes the prototype takes the
prototype shows it to the automobile
company
they love it shows it to his boss who
reluctantly says this is okay and that
was the invention of masking tape
imagine a world without masking tape
1924 was the year the last year the
world did not have masking tape now the
same guy Richard drew would go on a
couple years later to invent cellophane
tape scotch tape same guy now the
important part of story is not Richard
drew although that's interesting part of
the story
it's William McKnight because all
innovation we talked to this the
beginning they're all kind of all
innovators tend to be - like delinquents
and renegades and they push the limits
and it break the laws they break the
rules
- Richard's behavior fits that profile
but William McKnight is the magic part
of the story William McKnight looks at
this because he now has this cellophane
tape business it's masking tape business
that their profit curve goes on a curve
it's much greater than their sandpaper
business ever did series this new
division that came out of nowhere
not Minnesota not mine not manufacturing
Felix this goes you know I I screwed up
I'm the manager this company our most
profitable product now product line
because then you got all like the
special tapes and like the the special
dispensers and all you know the market
expansion stuff yeah I wanted to shut it
down so if I'm thinking of this company
the future I want to come how do I my
manager philosophies broken it's the
opposite I want a management philosophy
that encourages Richard drew that finds
researchers and brings them in says yeah
you know what even if you don't like
what even if I don't like what you're
doing I'm gonna give you some amount of
time to do it anyway
so William McKnight change the company
change director the company eventually
came to CEO of the company and made this
a core part of the philosophy of who
they hired and how decisions were made
so that's the story of how you get from
mining to post-it notes because that
person there was another part of the
progression of breaking into new fields
and trying out new ideas and allowing
individual engineers the authority to
develop things on their own now I'm
gonna read to you in a break a
presentation rule here this is a three
paragraph
piece of a lecture or paper that he
McKnight wrote about his management
philosophy and they're redoing to talk
about briefly as our business grows it
becomes increasingly necessary to
delegate responsibilities and to
encourage men and women to exercise
their initiative this requires
considerable tolerance those men and
women to whom we delegate authority and
responsibility if they
good people are going to want to do
their jobs in their own way mistakes
will be made but if a person's
essentially right the mistakes he or she
makes you're not as serious in the long
run as the mistakes management will make
if it undertakes to tell those in
authority exactly how they must do their
jobs management that is destructively
critical when mistakes are made kills
initiative it's essential that we have
many people with initiative if we are to
continue to grow and not only is that
much better written in almost any
executive CEO speech I've ever seen or
heard it was written in 1948 or spoke in
1948 it's almost exactly 60 years ago
and this philosophy as simple as it is
it's very rarely followed by managers
and leaders or for parents who say they
want their children or their employees
or their partners or their spouses or
their families to be creative and
innovative it's a very simple set of
things he's saying here one delegation
which is effectively trusts
what do you McKnight was saying I have
to trust Richard Roux that some of his
instincts are right even though I think
he's wrong trust day number two which is
the craziest one mistakes will be made
mistakes will be made
now I worked at Microsoft for a long
time I do consulting now on lots of
companies that visit lots of places and
do talks like this and I know a lot of
what management is based on and it's
exceptionally where you ever see a
manager and executive even if famous
companies who have in their business
plan for the year you know 10 million
dollars for equipment 20 million dollars
for marketing 8 million dollars for
mistakes that's our plan for this year
we want mistakes to go up by 10 percent
that's our goal
you will never hear that set so he put
it in it's the beginning of the second
paragraph or three prep mistakes that we
made because we want to take risks that
means we're gonna make mistakes he's not
saying that mistakes should be failures
in the marketplace he's not saying we
should deliberately tank products like
sabotage each other he's saying what we
said before you got to do seek
alternatives you got to find what's the
other way to do this let's try it out
and know that we're gonna learn we'll
prototype will learn what prototype
we'll learn then once we have a more
confidence we'll make bigger commitments
and actually develop products that's
really what he's saying he's making a
commitment the mistakes have to be made
and the last thing is about initiative
and he's recognizing that initiative is
something that he can't foresee that
Richard Drew's initiative
follow this project goes against the
view that McKnight will have as a CEO
what a valuable use of time is so who
hears heard of the Google 20% rule okay
so most those who don't know Google has
this philosophy that all employees get
20% of their time to do whatever they
want has to be a project that's it's
owned by the company it's like they can
go there and doodle or do knitting or
something but 20% this was to pick a
project and working on it eventually
those projects might become something
that become a product so Gmail
I think AdWords is a few others that
were started with 20% projects that's a
great thing and Google does a lot of
things right but this concept wasn't
invented by them he's been tipped by
this guy
so in somewhere in 1930 he created a
concept of 15% time so funny how we
inflate these things right 15% time
where he said exactly the same thing he
wanted a richer drew and every future
Richard Richard drew jr. Richard you
junior the third the whole line of
people he wanted them to come in and go
you know what my boss is wrong about
this so I have an outlet of time and
resources I can use my lab I have an
outlet of time for that energy to go
somewhere and I have the opportunity to
prove my boss wrong that explains that's
a very difficult thing to do that
explains but that's a very difficult
thing for most managers who see
themselves as being the center of
control very difficult thing to do so I
hold this up whenever I'm asked to to
come into a company to try any more
innovative try any more creative if I
want to take more risks this is he's got
it all down in three paragraphs and if
that's the philosophy you followed
innovation will happen risks will happen
people feel more confident following
ideas and they will have no they'll be
unable to complain that there's not an
outlet for them to pursue the passion
that they but the thing they believe in
that no one else does it's built into
the system so the last thing that I said
before right before I open up for
questions last thing that says even
though this comes from a management
perspective all of this stuff or almost
all the stuff applies on that individual
level as well because most of us are
trained were trained when we're children
were trained through most school systems
were trained through work to follow the
rules and we have a very critical view
of ourselves when we make mistakes if
you want to be an innovating yourself or
creative yourself you have to find a way
to allow yourself to
mistakes before you need the opportunity
from someone else have to allow yourself
to do it and a lot of what came up in
the creative thinking class was getting
people to be less critical of their own
ideas and to follow them further before
they kill them there's an opportunity
what this guy was saying for anyone to
become an innovator if they are willing
to accept the fact they will fail accept
the fact that some of things they come
up with will seem crazy and accept the
fact that like the whole Apple thing
being an innovator creator is something
that it's a personal responsibility no
one's going to come and tap you on the
shoulder and say now it's time to break
break the rule so like to thank you guys
for listening to me and if you like this
kind of thinking or these kind of
questions that you guys most that you
most you have copies of the book you
should check it out because the book
actually is probably better stories than
the ones I told you I try to save the
good stuff for the book anyway thank you
for coming and for listening to me
[Applause]